foreign
[Music]
do you know that feeling when you're
doing exactly what you were put on the
earth to do the one where it's like
everything inside you is moving together
in harmony with the universe
me neither
but you know one can hope right
wave to Mommy because she'll hate me
even more than she already does if you
don't I seem to recall you saying that
becoming a lawyer would only crush your
soul yeah it is
right now that business is getting a
journalist in and out of paldonia
no it's a one-off no no and no he's a
journalist I have resigned my position
here
20 grand says you are
welcome president finaga so nice to meet
you
you must take a selfie um
you approved
us
wow
what the hell just happened you're one
man's security detail happened he's a
human
the president of a country in the middle
of a coup this is the scoop of a
lifetime you got to be alive down the
scoop for a lifetime you never should
have come let's go you can't just leave
him
[Music]
all right
ready to go I don't know how to stop
when you start at the bottom I'm just
I'm just a job
did you help
get up again now I got to win I get up
again
the time for coaching man
[Music]
oh my God
Color Me impressed Mr petite
tell me you got that run
[Music]